do you think are your thoughts there's
nothing unique about your boss they've
been around for thousands of years
you're just tapping into them because of
what you're doing with your body that
makes you too fearful or passionate or
courageous or whatever you're feeling as
you go in those states you get different
thoughts whenever something bad happens
I tell myself it's the best we haven't
done a great job in Western culture of
teaching how to feel emotions label them
and then how to work with them rise and
shine it's an espresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message discipline your mind
over to you Tony Robbins also if you
want to hear what Tony Robbins and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building confidence check out my
250 for confidence series all of us have
kind of an identity for ourselves a way
of defining ourselves and human beings
don't usually stray from that if you
change the way you move your body
radically enough your voice your face
your movement your biochemistry changes
focus is controlled by questions every
day for the next 254 days I will send
you a 30-second two five-minute video
for free every morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below
we think there are thoughts or makes it
really hard to change them and people
meditate trying to not think possible
show me somebody has done that
successfully consistently the motion
everything the mind thinks thoughts but
here's the distinction if I told you a
hundred years ago we're gonna fly the
moon and back you called me a lunatic
that's where the term comes from people
still use it it doesn't make any sense
because a lunatic for somebody thought
we gotta move back we've done it right I
didn't know that but if I would have
told you a hundred years ago that
there's gonna be a box in your pocket
and you're gonna pull this thing out
you're gonna hit a couple buttons and
then it's gonna capture invisible waves
that are drifting around the earth and
bring the waves in and you're gonna see
somebody on the other side of the earth
and you're gonna talk to them you're
totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves and when you use your
body in a certain way if I sit like this
I'm gonna channel I'm gonna tap into a
different channel those waves that if
I'm sitting like this kind of like a TV
set if I turn one channel it might be a
comedy channel I'm gonna see a lot of
laughter turn another one it's a horror
channel turn another channel it's a
romance channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize that your
thoughts do you think are your thoughts
there's nothing unique about your
thoughts they've been around for
thousands of years you're just tapping
into them because of what you're doing
with your body that makes you too
fearful or passion or too courageous or
whatever you're feeling as you go in
those states you get different thoughts
so what I want people to see is that
learn how to just see those thoughts go
by it's learning how to be entertained
by those thoughts because I have crazy
thoughts then but what I've got good at
is going look at that crazy thought
That's not me that's the mind not your
mind cuz if it's you how do you change
you pretty hard but I really truly know
there's I haven't heard a thought come
out of you that's original you've called
them your thoughts but they're not
you've stolen them they've been around
forever when you see that it's easier to
let go of them and letting go of those
thoughts is one of the ways that you
free yourself and them again the more
you do it just like a muscle you get
better and better and better and all of
a sudden the [ __ ] that used to make you
crazy or stressed out I'm like how many
things you'd be worried about then never
came to be
and some people their life is good so
they worry about other people they're
never not worried right so it's really
just a pattern if you want wealth real
wealth is not just money it's emotion
it's like what are we really after in
money you know on money you want pieces
of paper with these pictures of deceased
notables on it you want we think money
will give you think it'll give you
freedom or security or stability or love
it won't give you a little get you sex
it won't get you love right so really
what you're after is the emotion and so
what I want people to get is the emotion
they want now and all it is is a new
habit it's learning to discipline this
mind right by realizing the mind
thoughts are out there and letting them
float by and constantly coming back to
what can I love about this what can I
appreciate it's like if you can learn to
love or at least appreciate start to
enjoy the things that used to get upset
about how much freedom would you have
how much more joy to have and I know
people got billions of dollars I've
coached them who is like holy they live
in scarcity all the time when man I'll
never forget he's screaming at his wife
I'm in the meat I mean I'm in the house
and he's screaming at his wife because
she spent some money on a bunch of
outfits and stuff like that he's a
multi-billionaire he couldn't spend all
his money in his lifetime and then he's
totally upset at his daughters in her
20s who spent some money too and I'm
like I pulled him aside afterwards and I
said what do you do this for and what do
you do it for it he's like well it's
just it's the principle thing I said no
the principle thing is do you love these
people and do you want them to have an
abundant life when you have you don't
have one loss but you live like you're
poor you know it's like I finally got
through them but so many people that's
why I say money doesn't change you money
magnifies who you are so you want to
expand the depth of who you are and free
yourself from suffering by just knowing
it's a pattern of thought and you can
change the pattern of thought one of the
ways I've been discipline my mind
recently is trying to reframe anything
negative and telling myself it's the
best this has been a kick I've been on
for the past couple months that whenever
something bad happens I tell myself it's
the best and so this came out of me
going to climb recon as an event in Palm
Springs and I met up with a fan of mine
Leo who is an awesome dude and he was
gonna film something with me we want to
drive over to the desert which is about
an hour outside of Palm
Brandee met me on this insanely hot day
you know 90 plus degrees and he tells me
Evan it's super hot outside do you still
want to go for this hour-long trip out
into the desert so yes it's do it Leah
I'm pumped
let's go is what I came for you know I'm
excited to see you let's do it then he
says well also my air conditioning is
broken and we won't have any AC for the
whole trip like let's do it this is the
best let's go I'm down I want to do it
let's keep going it's like and we can't
roll the windows down because if we're
filming it'll really ruin our audios so
we got a we've got to sit in this car in
this van the whole time and not have any
AC or windows yes leo I want to do it
let's go this is the best I want to go
let's do it come on come on
as soon as we get outside of the airport
already I'm already feeling heat I'm a
Canadian not used to the crazy 90-plus
degree weather we get into his car and
just sitting in the car for two seconds
I'm already sweating I'm already feeling
the heat like this is amazing
this is the best that reframed this is
the best I'm so pumped to do it and we
start driving and as we start driving it
gets so hot that the camera shuts to him
the camera malfunctions because it was
they got overheated so we decided to get
out on the street on this stretch of the
highway and film the videos there and
there's barbed wire fences and there's
bottles of pee on the floor and there's
a dildo on the ground and all of this
crazy stuff happening it's like this is
the best this is amazing I love it and
then we went from filming there to
filming at the YouTube event where we're
in this huge room and they're given away
all sorts of free stuff and just a
dichotomy of this super- crazy chaos
environment to this luxury one we're
getting a whole bunch of free stuff I
love both here's what I think I think
negativity is coming for you right I
think I lean in a positive it's amazing
all the great stuff that happens is the
best too but when the negative stuff
does happen it's not that you seek it
it's not that you're looking for it's
not that you want to invite it into your
life but when negativity does happen
what do you do how do you react what do
you think I choose
to discipline my mind to say when that
negativity comes I want to react in a
positive way
there's nothing neither good nor bad but
thinking makes itself
I want to react in a positive way I want
to see this as this is the best this is
my chance to shine we're gonna have an
amazing time through this chaos I love
it it's gonna be a great experience well
then people say okay awesome you know
you have to sit in a sweaty car that's
the best okay I get it but what happens
when there's some really big pain that
happens we're not just talking about
waiting for an elevator or standing in a
red light or one little thing didn't go
right in your schedule that day what
happens when your business fails what
happens when you want to quit what
happens when something major happens in
your life I aren't you think but that's
the best - I'm a big believer that your
purpose comes from your pain I think if
I didn't struggle and suffer so much and
starting my business I wouldn't be doing
this the total lack of self confidence
and self-worth that I had in the early
days of my business and feeling like I'm
putting in all this work and all this
effort and nothing is working out that
is the reason why I do what I do now my
individual pain and suffering is now the
reason why I'm out helping millions of
people and I think it's the same thing
for you I think your purpose comes from
your pain I think if if you have not
been through pain it's really hard to
have a strong purpose if you look at the
people who you look up to who are on a
mission who have a deep purpose they
want to change the way something is done
it's because of a deep pain that they
came from and I think ultimately humans
are good I think people are good I think
you want to serve I think when you've
been through something and you've come
out on the other side you not you want
to help other people who are going
through it now I want to help
entrepreneurs that so much because I
still feel the 19 year old version of me
struggling and suffering and I want to
help that guy ever and I want to help
you guys out so even when you get hit
with some big news not just as little
tiny okay you got to deal with hot
weather but big news that causes deep
pain still the best if you can reframe
what to say this is the best because
getting through this I will be able to
help millions of people who are going
through the same thing so how do we
apply it I'm going to give you two
suggestions first off try to reframe the
negativity you
as an exercise right now just think
about something negative that happened
right now think about maybe you were
staying in line at the coffee shop and
the person was rude to you or you stood
in line at a red light and it was really
frustrated too you're waiting for the
elevator or you spilled coffee all over
yourself right it's the best just
reframe it just take the negative thing
that happened to you right now today so
far yesterday a negative conversation
anything and just tell yourself this is
the best and try to find a reason why
and get used to that reframing every
single time something negative happens
you won't catch it all the time but the
more you practice catching it the more
you will catch it ongoing practice it
right now think about that one thing and
then think about how can that be the
best and then find another one and how
can that be the best and the next time
you're feeling negative frustrated upset
angry how can that be
the best if you have a hard time get out
of bed in the morning and you're
frustrated and sad and angry but
yourself if you do it like tomorrow wake
up and do it and the next day do it you
get out of bed or still suffer for the
next three months getting out of bed
understand why is it the best how is
that the best because when you figure
out and how to do it when you get out of
bed you will be able to help millions of
other people grow that same problem as
you so this struggle the fight the
effort is the best and to think about
your purpose coming from your pain
people like to avoid their pain we want
to run from pain we never want to
remember the pain social entrepreneurs
we like to lean in on a positive and the
optimistic which is amazing but the
answer is to jump head into your pain
not run away from it you dive into it
and in there is the answer for you
should be doing with your life and your
business write this down what is your
biggest pain whether it was growing up
whether it happened last year like
what's what are some of the most painful
moments in your life and try to remember
it then you may have a block you may
have tried to wipe that from your memory
don't do that that's your purpose line
in there write down the most painful
moments in your life and then see how is
that the best not because it happened to
you because that sucked but how do you
turn it from that negative situation
into you being able to serve others
that's how it becomes the best that
painful moment that you had
how can you use that to serve other
people write that down now I've got a
really special bonus clip for you but
before that question today I want to
know what was your pain and how have you
turned that into your purpose how was
your biggest pain in your life the best
leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoyed the bonus clip
[Music]
you know there's only a handful of
primary emotions and unfortunately we're
not we haven't done a great job in
Western culture of teaching how to feel
emotions label them and then how to work
with them you know we don't have I
didn't have that course I don't know if
you did and I didn't have a course on
how you know the basic mental skills
work how to label them and how to train
them so we haven't done a great job of
doing this in the education platform and
if there's only three things we can
train craft body in mind like why are we
not training the mind like what why are
we because the way that thoughts and
emotions work it's like a bang bang
experience they happen like right next
to each other and there's some
conversation about what comes first is
it a thought then emotion or is it
emotion than a thought most people in
the field would say of psychology would
say it's thought than emotion the way
that I think about this is that's like a
rider in the in an elephant so the rider
is the thought and then as soon as the
emotion wants to run because the thought
that maybe the rider scared he's having
scary thoughts or sad because he's
having a lot of sad base thoughts that
it's when the L if it wants to go when
the emotions run you're not controlling
that thing your job my job is to be the
rider a thoughtful aware rider of
thoughts and when we're able to be aware
of our thoughts then we can guide and
negotiate our thoughts so they don't run
while ultimately there's a meta
awareness that takes place where when
you train awareness and we I'd like to
get into that conversation with you when
you train awareness of your thoughts
emotions body sensations and your
environment awareness of your
environment those four things we become
more finely tuned so that we can choose
great thoughts we can harness our
emotions we can feel our body sensations
and use them to facilitate clear
thinking creative thinking or great
output and when we're more aware of the
unfolding unpredictable environment
around us we can course correct and
adjust and pivot and that makes all the
difference in the most intense
environments in the world whether that's
an emotional intensity vulnerability or
that is you know center court whatever
sporting environment that we're talking
about now terrific world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful
I understand why I'm here I think
because I am so open I wanted to think
and see it's a bloody brief life all of
you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what Gary
v-d-j Khalid Oprah and others know about
empire building that most people miss
check out the link in the description
for a free bonus video